when people leave comments on YouTube
you suck you're not funny you're not
interesting feel bad for them because if
they have enough time to leave a
negative comment on your channel there
they've lost you focus on the positives
put out content and here's the number
one key document don't create don't
overthink it
you can produce unlimited content every
day every day every day obviously have
school and other things but don't be
crippled don't be romantic just
dududududu don't listen
do-do-do-do-do delicious
[Music]
[Music]
loudly
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this was last Monday morning in your
life
we're in London right now
so Gary and I left New York at 6:25 p.m.
I was in our flight left but this quite
stuck up to London going to make some
magic happen across the pond 24 hours
off you taste out
when you leave it take twenty five or
six thirty whatever you're not tired so
you can't go to bed and when you arrive
in London you started to be in a day
[Music]
forget about my brother let me grumbled
every from Facebook Lenny I was so
important to me I just wanted to do the
fact that that believes the modern day
commercial influencer marketing I want
to be I want to go deep and execute or
clients that you know donkey
[Music]
we can say the world will get full what
up what I pay much more attention to
they think about retention and flow not
how much thinking you know what are
these boring laps like what is you know
like that's what I'm more fascinated by
like are they on the office but they
know how to ask them do they have the
senior relations like one biggest things
on pushing everybody for more insight
farming not housing you know yeah I
think last year was very passive and
wanted to walk the magical behavior of
like leadership plus we had a whole week
restructuring of our creative
capabilities really I mean so many real
60 CDs now with non
come again like a game of Tetris let's
make some moves on the baby shuttle
still the issue with even nations and
combination let me try my chicken over
your say me why the hell today my
bathroom is 57 my pleasure to perceive
again within your create momentum and
this may be questions that means we're
dimensions we could take it to the class
are you will be blessed
it's time to get moving gotta get I am
like we all match right here in our
fight night Peter brother touched let me
give my life type all these reflections
we just wanna be man yeah we gonna do
about going in to see a potential client
no Kara's alive yeah Raph
[Music]
the publication's of my patient who
witnessed the struggle and the one who
detained table that was fun first
meeting in the bag just really like kind
of perspective was walking out of this
incredible to be sitting in the room
with one of the biggest companies in the
world and I'm just having a level of
conversation we're having around content
and distribution I mean when we started
being over the edge I sort of inor 2009
pentomino Facebook was that you know
people didn't even believe in digital
and here we are you know eight short
years later and and people really having
detailed knowledgeable conversations
just fun to see the world evolve and I'm
sure the pioneers of television had that
sense of that blood in the water right
that okay it's coming it's coming and so
you know people are not being romantic
about radio anymore they're starting
their standard televisions real
televisions in every hole is so I'm
excited baseball commercials and
influencer marketing will continue to be
the big push like in the org so two
things one I just want that in your mind
even look even like I liked the idea of
that being in your mind for you walking
down the street ran delay and saying to
yourself you know what I'm going to ping
an DK from Gary Samore honor you may not
even know that great so I'm gonna pick
Andy I just want to get the analytics on
Gary's long-form videos on Facebook or
things like you know what I'm head up
just wall D or dong court like it's just
gonna be the thing and so the more your
brain knows that the better
you remember people excite you in my
mind
- enjoy this table with my one good mic
on screaming run try this and I'm trying
to move my peoples my daughter she was
in the lot and I miss all we all trip on
the fly
gotta make it up another do a pivot
billion by nine-thirty brother boy gotta
stop till I don't even in this baby was
a baby Bahamas I'm willing club y'all so
only my silence with the people who knew
open we can time that better such an
opinion but you'll be here coming we're
gonna do a border people work ability to
you can't forget about my brother's
struggle if he fumbled and we crumble
will give it's one piece I love one out
all day just spread out
we can play the world one day so [ __ ]
good listening oh my god
money feel silly I'm from Manchester bog
to travel to all the way down here was
an hour from the trains to gaya just
diseases be human fly said last year but
this year I'm going to come and see Gary
Vee a friend of mine said you know what
I might know something for a like yeah I
was like [ __ ] I need to be dead I'm
running so late for mean do you want to
get a picture um yeah can I get a
picture but I really wanted to run
something over with you Hussain as we're
doing it ok and now maybe we'll set up
an actual call because I'm really really
late well yeah we already talked
yeah quality give me please and compound
events really right now yeah and
probably like right now right now yeah
don't oppose Tyler I'll get a subpoena
operator give me the framework yeah
it's a sport pass it thank you for let
it go yeah I mean I can I can jump in
here I mean I think you know from my
perspective first of all thanks for your
time we're you know I'm always paying
attention to market behaviors and things
that are going on in culture and and how
I interplay with them from a personal
brand side and my agency side and you
guys have really crushed it it's super
impressive and truth is I'm not really
looking for anything at all I and other
than starting to meet people and build
relationships and my my favorite my
favorite move is how do I bring value I
am yeah I'd love to meet you and get a
better sense of like how you're thinking
about things and like hear your story
and his backstory and your overall
arching kind of like world as well I
love reverse engineering right like the
more I know like I'm real real long-term
so like three years from now nine years
from now so I I think it's a marathon so
I'd love to me too and I don't even like
phone calls like I just really love
face-to-face so I'm looking forward to
that you come through New York once in a
while not that often it's you know to me
it's a good time of year I would
recommend getting to Chicago if you can
because they're still planning their
money you wait to March or April when
he's in New York they may not even have
it even if they wanted to do something
so that's my recommendation there and
then Mike work with Tyler and get us
together in New York I'm away the next
two weeks filming my show in LA but I'll
be back after that
[Music]
so I posted something about
saying you're an entrepreneur is
different than being an entrepreneur
somebody left in the comments that they
said they usually agree with me but then
once in a while I just blow up and and
blow it and and their point was that
teachers teach they don't degrade their
audience so interesting to need that a
statement like that is interpreted as a
negative actually think I'm helping I'm
trying to help the millions of kids that
have been sold of the propaganda that
entrepreneurship is for everybody and
they're not willing to self-awareness
they actually are and so to me just
because you're getting critical feedback
doesn't mean you're hurting somebody I
think we've gotten so soft in a lot of
arenas that even debating something that
may feel not warm and fuzzies is met
with the thoughts that it's a negative I
can tell you right now that my parents
taught me a ton of [ __ ] that wasn't
delivered with honey and so I think we
need to debate what teaching is really
about and more importantly that there
are many deliveries styles and ways to
deliver a message and not all of us
react the same way to every one of them
and so some people respond extremely
well to one way and some respond to
elderly
the year market trying to provide value
is trying to reach the communicate from
many different people many different
ways
[Music]
what up into the grandma love you guys
I'll be doing well that's it Robert hey
are you sure it's big bad Rock
oh yeah
[Music]
yo hey
I'll decide
and then Cynthia I know an airline
that's right that have some bad ones
that good one hey are you feeling up
Consuela
such a pleasure hey how are you really
well no I'm really I've not figured out
my way I've got to figure it out but I
think I got a concept assignment market
real pleasure
okay okay
cannoli opens evening my book I'm going
to Katerina Moser
yeah how are you I know what I mean yeah
how do we sit there and yeah well I feel
really good here tonight it's awesome
yeah we going to start up good we're
going to take off in seven so awesome
good luck I'll let you go in there
running around with you oh how are you
garrison thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah good I'm really good it is super
duper honoring River thanks man very
kind thank you very said I think you
gotta do is exact enough of my music and
that option for people it isn't much
tell me to take a breather smile fans in
the blood just make it quick in the
Petersons Jewish people for done I dare
you we'll continue the conversation a
friend oh can you sense can you send
this to me in digital form Gary at
vaynermedia there's some me okay
I just want to it's great granularity
I'm a weird dude I make way more
decisions on this that I will on that
what I tend to do is I want to make sure
that you're not vulnerable to what
matters to me
the guy was about to get blown out and
like just didn't hear me cool I didn't
see release let's say well
[Music]
it's XA in focus
[Music]
hey remember yet support I'm going to
make a big fun Thank You Man 2 it
everything you think about it there's
not too many people working here like a
less bulky so the premium to do it can I
love yeah well video or pictures I'm the
only look I don't wanna keep it on then
thank you for the love take care
[Music]
tomorrow
yes all right London going to head out
filling in the hotel now going to go
work out I got to work out now
whatever it is 10 o'clock and then I got
to look at a 6:00 a.m.
[ __ ] shorten see ya tomorrow
so guys and I don't know trick 11 or so
news quickly ten ten ten ten
Julian's making me do three hundred
push-ups the next 40 minutes and let's
come to trip from New York to London no
sleep and then because I needed to get a
quick one hour nap in not to work out at
10:10 and tomorrow get at 6:00 a.m.
yeah what you going to morrow leg yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]